you in the office you'll wait for me
there after the second Bell so I can
dismiss the rest of the class does
anyone else want to try my authority
because I am [ __ ] done playing with
you idiots
I am here because I want to be here
I somewhat enjoy this job
I'm here cause I want to be here I'm
here because I want to educate you guys
and I don't feel any reciprocity
the energy are literally opposite
for everyone who's watching doesn't know
basically this is a teacher who went on
a rant I in class after what Susan said
something so I'll explain a little bit
more afterwards but let's keep watching
you
you nothing from you you can go through
life and live on the [ __ ] system draw
your paycheck on the person the 15th
from my taxes and with just an absolute
horrible life I don't care
you can be another statistic
I don't care
that's on you
and if you think it's funny I can take
you down to the county office and we'll
pull the [ __ ] numbers and if you
don't like my language I don't give a
[ __ ]
because you've said words and again
somehow you believe to get out now get
your [ __ ] get out get out now onion
so he caught her filming and then he
told her to get out and she's like I'm
not it's like you're a chewing gum in
class let's not protect
so if you guys want me I mean
so context
I'm gonna tell you guys how this started
he was in class he's been having issues
with class in this class in school in
general for quite some time yeah
he tells the people in the class please
put your phones and your laptops away
yeah he repeats it a few times and then
finally one of the kids like fine I'll
put my laptop I don't want I'm gonna do
it before this guy starts whining and
whining again and then he loses it
that's funny okay that's funny one two
this receives a lot of backlash people
felt like his comments were racially
charged and he put in his resignation
the next day that's funny so
that's the general context of what
happened the girl afterwards has come
out and be like I felt like what he said
was so racially insensitive and this and
that so I'll let you go first what are
your thoughts that's actually funny that
this you're showing me this right now
why last week
last week just last week I was out of
school
giving
um a conference to give conference to
kids about the impact of social media on
them like we go from the positive things
the bad things and we talk about a bit
uh we talk a bit about
um bullying and stuff like that right
online and offline and stuff like that
so I talk about my experience and then
the teachers tell them to put their
phones away numerous times and I'm
talking and I'm talking and I'm talking
and there's a guy in the back and I'm
like yo
put your phone away and I was about that
there's a bit that I talk about their
phone right I'm like
let your phone away and while I'm saying
put your phone away good this dude right
in front of me yeah I'm in an auditorium
right so I'm on the stage they're right
there it's not the lights are not closed
it's it's it's it's open open lights all
right this guy takes his phone and I and
he's texting someone and I'm like and
I'm like yo put your [ __ ] phone away
dude I'm telling this dude to put his
phone away you put your foot what the
hell you talking about bruh and at the
minute at the beginning I was talking
about respect I'm like that's exactly
what I'm talking about I don't give a
[ __ ] about you little kid I went in I
went in I don't give a [ __ ] about you
you understand I could roast you that's
my job you understand I could disrespect
your whole family I don't care I could
disrespect your mom doing like you can't
talk about my mom if you want respect
you're gonna have to give it I don't
care I'll talk about your mom no you
have to respect no [ __ ] you have to
respect I ain't one of your little
friends and I'm not and I'm not the
teachers I do not care I made it
you're the one struggling bee
I'm giving you tips for life just have
the respect of listening to the
[ __ ] that's it I didn't say
[ __ ] because that's a bit much
but I was like yo I snapped on the kid
and we had like a little verbal back and
forth I'm not gonna send you I'm not
gonna send you to the office I'm gonna
tell you you'll have a little bit of
respect that's respect all of you always
want everybody to talk to you with
respect but you're the first one to have
total disregard and I told I told him I
understand
I understand because I was in a
situation where you were and I saw
people disrespect the teacher in high
school I had to put myself between two a
girl that was about to clock a teacher
in her face a whole a no lady that's not
it
all these people want respect they're
not even they're not able to give it so
entitled to yeah I'm in class whatever
teach me you're supposed to do your job
whatever shut up you also have to give
respect to people you also have a job if
you go to school you also have a job to
be there in the respect that people are
talking to you putting your phone to it
like you don't you don't care you don't
give a [ __ ] but I'm here
this cool care for you and paid me I'm
paid
I'm paid I'm talking about you
I'm talking to you about things that are
very important that you need in your
life
you put your phone up Come on B that's
what you want to do and after that
you're going to claim I want respect at
this point I don't need to respect you
and I don't care and the thing about the
teachers is that they spend so much time
and it's a hard [ __ ] job it's a hard
job that it doesn't get its recognition
and you're just gonna [ __ ] on the person
oh it's really racially strong y'all
don't care
you know your face is your money maker
the first thing that people see and you
have to take care of that I understand
that it's not for everybody it's not
everybody that know how to do it and
know how to take care of their skin well
that's a wonderful timing that you have
here because we have this wonderful
project that I'm using to clear off
everything in my skin and my Paws th H
Henley what I would suggest you to do I
suggest you to take and to start with
the level one system because it's a box
what kind of products they got in the
Box I'm about to tell you right now well
first of all they have a face wash they
want to get all in the nooks and
crannies all the pores keep all the
grime out boom they have a moisturizer
as a SPF uh 20 in there you don't want
to have a little protection from the Sun
they have instruction with the products
that you're gonna use to tell you when
to use the products how to use the
products go on the link below right now
click on the link below and save 30 off
your first purchase and also you can get
a free gift from thiege Henley I'm just
saying if you wash your booty wash your
beauty
that was genius y'all don't care if
you're the type of class that you're the
type of class that you are hold up she's
chewing gum in class
I'm not gonna front you when I was a kid
nobody could do it no nobody could do
that nobody out here filming chocolate
while he's losing it nobody you can
already tell what attitude she got with
him nobody could do that okay nobody
could do that also everything you said
to that Kindle auditorum you can say
that because you're not a teacher I'm
not a teacher so you can't say that but
what I'm trying to say is and most of us
will look at you and say it's Justified
for you to go and say that to the kid a
teacher can't say nothing no because
then here's the thing when you try to
hold a student accountable the parent
gets in the way and says how dare you
say any of that to my kids yeah but it's
like your kid is disruptive or your kid
doesn't want to put in the f word or
whatever it might be or they're just
disrespectful but you have no recourse
already it's not the best paying job
definitely not in most places a terrible
paying job secondly it's like you have
zero to little control over the
curriculum and any of the stuff that you
want to teach a kid so it's like you're
handcuffed thirdly stress in terms of
mental health issues teachers deal with
a lot
and it's like these are the people who
are supposed to be shaping the next
generation of folks and they spend
sometimes the most amount with their
kids more than anybody else and it's
like they are giving little to no
support so people see a blow up like
this like fire him resignation it's like
how did the teacher get there um you
think they came in the first day and
they were like that the first year the
first three years no
definitely not
but the system can wear you down that's
why you have teachers resigning in mass
and they have been over the last years
you have shortages in some places
because the thing is though as well it's
a thankless job whenever the kids [ __ ]
up the parents don't back nobody I'm not
saying that the teachers are always
right no but for the little things like
from grades to just them being who they
are in class they don't get the backup
of the schools they don't get the backup
of the parents of anything nothing
happened if about in my days when
[ __ ] when the teachers used to
call Ma my house if they would call it
would mean a rap at home it would have
been a whole rap
but that don't don't happen no more that
it does not happen right for whatever
whatever reason so they don't get the
recognition so yeah and I was not a
teacher so I and there was two teachers
walking me watching me and they knew I
was not a teacher and I was allowed to
say that
I told him I didn't give a [ __ ] about
him yeah I don't give a [ __ ] about you
but it's gonna have a if you want that
respect you won't have to you have to
you want to that [ __ ] as far as the
racial component goes I think people
have an issue with what was said because
it came from a white person but let me
say this there's a bunch of black
teachers who say the exact same things
to black students all the time regards
to you're likely to turn up as a
statistics you keep going like this why
because the teachers can literally see
these kids develop and to the point
where they [ __ ] up their whole lives if
you've never been to those schools I
know because I've either taught in those
schools or spent a lot of time them if
you've never been there you don't
understand how quickly the transition
they don't even finish high school a lot
of the times you see it so how often
they go through school will dictate how
the rest of their life will go for a lot
of the folks so you sitting back your
butt well that's
trust me black teachers are saying a lot
of the same stuff to these students yeah
I've heard it I've heard it to me
personally my high school years were the
worst I was getting in fights all the
time I was getting suspended so often I
didn't even finish
and if you wouldn't have made a change
then could have been really rough hence
the military came in but it's not like I
was on a good trajectory what being
arrested a bunch of times what how so
when I'm hearing that I don't care if it
came from a white person or a black
person the truth Remains the truth and
until we reform some of this education
in terms of funding like there's a whole
Litany of problems when it comes to the
education system now I can't even really
parse that what I'm trying to say is
like teachers are put in an untenable
position expected to educate and shake
these kids well they go in with that
aspiration and they find out it's so
difficult God forbid one day someone
lose it oh I'm gonna put my laptop
before this guy starts whining him
whining and whining is that what you
think I'm doing when I'm up here trying
to teach y'all [ __ ] and I put in work
and I've been making effort this whole
day to set up this [ __ ] teaching plan
whining it wanting why not just ask you
for a basic respect of course I'm gonna
empathize with the teacher even though
he resigned and even though you
shouldn't be blowing up at kids like
that it's like how much can you take so
until people want to have an honest
discussion about how handcuffed and how
untenable teaching jobs are for a lot of
people in certain school districts I
don't want to hear from people who want
a grandstand be like you can't act like
that you can't act like that well then
you cool trying to teach in those
schools and try to thrive there's a
reason why they got high turnover rates
why the teachers Never Last and the ones
who do they're the ones that don't give
a [ __ ] they're the ones who will see
kids acting crazy and just sit there
with a book out they don't give a [ __ ]
about it's not the kind of teachers you
want you should want teachers who are
emotionally invested
you should 100 want those because those
are the only teachers that ever marked
me in my whole life the one the two
teachers I made are the ones who pulled
me aside said something's wrong
not the ones who didn't give a [ __ ] so
of course I feel some type of way and is
he lying don't talk to me about the
racial component is he lying because go
to those neighborhoods go to those areas
and tell me that a lot of those kids
won't turn on to statistics but you want
to get through them you want to try to
save them you want to try to help these
people
but the system doesn't allow you to do
so because the system is more concerned
with their points with how they appeal
in the school district so they're
concerned with a bunch of other stuff
that doesn't really matter in terms of
kids future and they don't want the
grade they don't want any test pass and
they don't want to teach us that they
will go under the parents to be pissed
off too because the parents file
complaints it's a headache for them so
they come down is on tenable
so I just wanted to say that because I
saw this clip and it made me feel some
type of way and honestly do think that
yeah when it comes to kids in this not
even the cell phone but just like the
lack of respect that folks seem to have
for teachers just like I can't imagine
anything else no let us know what you
guys think in the comments below we want
to hear from you what do you guys do you
guys are great disagree let us know this
little [ __ ] was like oh what if
it's in an emergency my parents need to
call me they know you in school stupid
yeah that's just [ __ ]